with the collapse of the sontha Blanca  cartel you thought the war was over you  were wrong Leo Tolstoy once said that  the two most powerful warriors are  patience and time sometimes you don't  have either in which case the only thing  that matters is how fast you could pull  that trigger  there's no greater tactic than deception  and the noisemaker is a master of this  his modified drone emits gunfire sounds  to divert his prey drawing them into his  trap  additionally the stealth drone is  completely undetectable by enemies the  assassin is a highly mobile stealth unit  that is lethal and close-range  engagements  she cannot be marked by enemies from  further than 50 meters away  the sentinel is a hunter but of a  different Hill his SATCOM ability allows  him to select an area for traction the  first enemy that enter will be marked  alone your tier 1 combative  you